voilà nous avons fermé notre boutique le
11 décembre suite à la façon
de l'énergie des matières premières le
manque de clientèle au niveau de notre
village ainsi que aucun soutien de notre
mère
et aussi à la hausse des plantations des
chaînes
d'accord alors je peux vous demander
dans quel village dans quelle région de
France dans le Doubs dans le Doubs dans
le doux d'accord un village de combien
d'habitants 2800 habitants 2800 vous
êtes qui est la seule boulangerie la
seule ok un village dans le Doubs de
2800 habitants qui n'a plus de
boulangerie aujourd'hui voilà
vous l'avez ouverte quand la boulangerie
on l'a ouvert
2019 septembre 2019 septembre 2019
c'était votre premier commerce ou vous
en aviez déjà ouvert auparavant annuler
oui
à nous deux oui à vous deux il y en a un
ou deux qui étaient boulangers
auparavanté mon coup dans un petit
village compenser être sympathique
ben c'est pas le cas voilà
aujourd'hui vous aviez une facture
d'électricité qui a augmenté vraiment
considérablement ou pas
on va dire pas vraiment 20% le plus
c'est pas ça c'est plus les matières
premières c'est à dire la levure plus
importante
le sucre et la farine 60% d'augmentation
donc à un moment la baguette vous pouvez
pas la mettre à 5 euros quoi ah bah non
on n'aurait pas pu là on aura augmenté
on aura encore perdu encore deux fois
plus de clients au moment où vous avez
fermé votre votre boulangerie vous
vendiez la baguette combien
et donc c'est le prix des matières
premières vraiment qui a eu raison de
votre commerce
d'activité c'était un peu moins de gens
qui venaient chercher du pain voilà oui
parce qu'ils ont vous avez esquissé
peut-être qu'il y avait des grands
groupes c'était installé à côté du
village et qui ont raflé de la clientèle
un kilomètre 8 qu'ils étaient ils sont
implantés alors quel est votre question
pour monsieur le ministre
vu notre situation
on a pu revenu
là j'avance on était à l'artisan
maintenant on exploiteur
et je voudrais savoir ce que peut faire
le gouvernement
quand vous êtes squatteur c'est que vous
n'êtes pas propriétaire ni locataire de
votre logement et vous ne payez plus le
loyer c'est ça on n'est plus du tout de
revenus aujourd'hui non plus du tout
vous avez je devine votre tranche d'âge
je vais pas vous demander votre âge
précis ça se fait pas mais d'accord
est-ce que vous avez des projets c'était
une fermeture brutale ou une fermeture
de boulangerie que vous avez pu vous
avez vu venir sur plusieurs semaines et
que vous avez anticipé
à savoir ce que vous voulez ce que vous
voulez faire et puis on s'est dit non on
ferme parce que si leur on aurait
continué on a encore augmenté les
factures
c'est bon on arrête et là vous avez des
dettes que vous n'arrivez pas à payer
oui des lourdes ou pas
c'est déjà trop bon
bah si déjà vous n'arrivez pas à payer
le loyer actuellement et vous êtes
heureux et qu'en plus ce que je pose la
question qu'est-ce que vous aimeriez
faire vous voulez ouvrir une boulangerie
ailleurs ou
autre situation ça va pas être madame
avant de rejoindre votre besoin aussi
d'accord oui tous les deux vous avez des
expériences boulangerie auparavant juste
pour savoir la boulangerie en 2019 quand
vous l'avez ouverte elle marchait bien
ah oui Oui au niveau des deux premières
années oui on a très bien bossé d'accord
les gens étaient contents qu'on était
ouvert et puis à la troisième année
d'accord donc voilà c'est une
boulangerie vous étiez content vous
gagnez vous gagnez votre vie
correctement vous étiez assez content
mais bon oui mais vous en sortir
combien de combien d'argent pour vous
quand ça marchait pour nous on est à
10003 par personne ou à deux à deux
c'était extrêmement limite déjà
alors il y a beaucoup de sujet d'abord
je suis absolument désolé de ce que vous
décrivez parce que je vois en plus votre
émotion et je sais que c'est pas je
devine que c'est c'est une situation
très compliquée à vivre pour vous il y a
pas mal d'éléments dans ce que vous me
dites alors c'est vrai que d'abord il y
a la hausse des matières premières qui
est une réalité parfois il y a un peu
d'incompréhension face à cette hausse et
matière première puis parfois vous
entendez que c'est lié à la gare en
Ukraine et vous dites pourquoi le prix
du beurre il est lié au la guerre en
Ukraine en réalité c'est un peu plus
complexe que ça d'abord il y a le
problème du lait c'est à dire que le
lait avait atteint un coup de ventes par
nos agriculteurs tellement bas qu'il y a
un certain nombre d'agriculteurs qui ont
arrêté de produire du lait et donc comme
il y avait moins de lait et bien le ça
coûtait un peu plus cher c'était un peu
plus rare finalement à trouver pour
fabriquer pour fabriquer du beurre
ensuite vous avez des coups de transport
vous avez des coûts des céréales pour
nourrir les animaux on n'imagine pas
mais les céréales ça vient beaucoup du
crâne et le les céréales quand elles le
prix augmente et bien ça peut augmenter
le prix de la viande augmenter le prix
du bétail de l'entretien du bétail et ça
fait aussi augmenter du coup le prix du
lait vous avez aussi la sortie de la
crise covid ou le monde est devenu un
peu fou c'est pas qu'en France en Europe
partout il y a des prix qu'on commençait
à zigzaguer dans tous les sens parce que
les matières premières coûtaient etc
chers et donc c'est vrai que quand le
prix des matières premières augmentent
vous pouvez être contraint d'augmenter
le prix du produit que vous avez
fabriqué vous-même en l'occurrence du
pain des croissants des viennoiseries
des gâteaux or vous vous êtes à portée
de baffe et vous n'êtes pas le dirigeant
d'un grand supermarché non seulement
vous pouvez pas diversifier votre
activité c'est-à-dire vous pouvez pas
dire je fais moins de marge sur les
baguettes donc je vais vendre d'autres
trucs un boulanger vous pouvez vendre
d'autres trucs mais de façon limitée et
puis surtout en fait les gens vous
voient le matin et ils voient le soir et
puis quand ils voient que le prix des
produits augmentent et ben ils vous
disent pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
augmenté les prix donc tout ça c'est que
c'est extrêmement compliqué quand on a
une hausse de matière première alors
vous dites le coût de l'énergie n'a pas
n'a pas impacté fortement les choses
peut-être parce que vous aviez un
contrat qui était déjà signé avant la
montée du prix d'énergie donc c'est
moins un sujet pour vous l'autre
problème que l'autre enjeu que je vois
c'est pour la vie de votre village alors
je vais pas dire de bêtises je crois
qu'il y a 30 30 et quelques milles
boulangers en France il y a à peu près 6
milliards de baguettes de mémoire qui
sont vendus chaque année 12 millions de
clients par jour donc c'est vraiment le
commerce de proximité par excellence et
donc ce qui veut dire que lorsque la
boulangerie du village ferme et ben
c'est un peu du village qui meurt c'est
à dire qu'il y a moins de gens qui se
retrouvent qui se rassemblent qui se
croisent au centre du village et donc il
faut trouver des solutions et donc faut
être capable de penser d'autres
solutions alors il y a des choses qui
pourraient vous être proposées vous avez
parlé du maire je le connais pas et j'ai
pas envie de rentrer si vous en êtes
d'accord dans un débat sur est-ce que le
maire vous a accompagné ou non néanmoins
il y a des dispositions qui existent je
vais vous citer un exemple moi je suis
zéroi je viens de Grenoble c'est la
grande ville mais à une heure il y a un
petit village qui s'appelle le village
de taux dur qui fait un village très
sympa mais dans lequel les commerces
étaient plutôt en train de fermer les
uns après les autres
il y a une belle initiative qui est
portée par une association qui s'appelle
le Groupe SOS qui s'appelle l'initiative
des 1000 café qui est donc à taux dur
ils ont ouvert un café mais qui n'est
pas qu'un café c'est un café associatif
tenu par quelqu'un je crois qu'il était
alors il était peut-être pas boulanger
peut-être restaurateur donc ça aurait pu
être un boulanger et qui diversifie son
activité c'est-à-dire ils vont à la fois
du pain à la fois des journaux il
produit un certain nombre de services ça
restaure de la vie au cœur des villages
et c'est vraiment un de nos gros
objectifs c'est de faire en sorte que
les commerces ouvrent dans les villages
et qu'ils arrêtent de fermer il y a un
village sur deux dans notre pays qui n'a
aucun commerce aucun commerce et ça
c'est absolument pas normal donc on a
besoin de vous donc je comprends que
vous soyez peut-être écœuré fatigué
inquiet et vous n'avez pas envie de
reproduire l'expérience mais sachez que
on a besoin quand même très fortement
d'artisans comme vous avec du
savoir-faire pour pouvoir s'implanter
dans les endroits alors peut-être que
cette expérience a pas marché n'est
qu'une autre pourrait marcher ça on peut
vous accompagner on va on va on va
revenir sur Raphaël dans un instant je
voudrais juste avoir est-ce que je suis
bien et dans le public ce boulanger qui
avait fermé qui était venu sur mon
plateau qui lui vous avez vu sa facture
d'électricité flambée comme comme jamais
il est là
Julien merci d'être là Julien
bonsoir donc moi je suis Julien
effectivement donc ça fait 17 ans que je
suis dans le métier de la boulangerie et
j'avais mon commerce durant 5 ans et
comme mes confrères j'ai fermé à la même
période avant les fêtes parce que
c'était plus possible les enchaînements
des matières premières les charges et
l'électricité qui nous a complètement
plombé quoi donc au bout d'un moment on
peut plus supporter le travail 90 heures
semaine Julien est-ce que vous pouvez à
Monsieur le Ministre
quel a été votre facture d'électricité
ouais donc au bout d'un moment on a
essayé comme on a pu de rogner sur les
marges on a augmenté les prix on a
licencié on a essayé de faire tout ce
qu'on a pu pour garder le village
sain parce que voilà c'est comme mes
collègues j'étais le seul commerce du
village la seule boulangerie le seul
lieu de rencontre en fait pour que les
les gens les personnes mobilité réduite
les anciens du village se réunissent
donc du coup ouais moi j'ai pris
l'empreinte vraiment l'impression
d'avoir laissé mourir mon village en
fait ouais alors voilà les gens vous ont
vu partir avec vous avez du soutien au
sein du village du soutien pour le coup
de énormément
c'est les gens ils sont encore là
d'ailleurs je reçois des courriers tous
les jours et tout j'ai un soutien
phénoménal et c'est très important le
moral parce que voilà moi j'ai fait une
petite dépression quand même après parce
que voilà on est combien de temps vous
avez tenu votre boulangerie 5 ans 5 ans
c'était votre premier commerce c'était
mon premier commerce ouais ok est-ce que
vous avez vu donc vous c'est le c'est le
coup l'électricité qui a été le coup de
grâce voilà c'est pas j'ai eu ma facture
j'ai fermé mais c'était vraiment le coup
de grâce en fait on a essayé comme je
vous dis les matières premières depuis
cet été les charges qui ont augmenté et
puis bah l'électricité ça a mis le coup
de massue en trop quoi alors est-ce que
vous avez vu parce que vous avez fermé
en décembre vous m'avez dit en décembre
vous avez vu que depuis le début d'année
2023 alors c'est c'est tard pour vous le
projet de
[Musique]
et des TPE qu'on appelle énergivor
c'est-à-dire des TPE qu'on ne
consommation électrique importante moi
je me suis rendu dans une boulangerie en
région parisienne il y a quelques
semaines j'ai je me suis essayé à la
fabrique du pain c'était pas un succès
mais c'était pas pour ça que j'y étais
mais pour discuter avec l'artisan
boulanger qui est effectivement fait
face à une hausse de ses factures parce
que en fait le four utilise beaucoup
d'énergie la conservation au frais aussi
en chambre froide des produits tout ça
est très énergivore et donc ce qu'on a
décidé comme règle vous l'avez peut-être
vu c'est qu'en fait vous avez des
boulangers
qui sont pas soumis à la hausse du prix
d'énergie parce que eux ils ont signé
des contrats sur plusieurs années il y a
il y a un an où il y a six mois et donc
en fait ils ont signé un contrat qui les
engagent à leur fournisseur d'énergie
pendant deux ou trois ans et donc eux
l'énergie augmente mais comme ils sont
liés par leur contrat ils sont protégés
et vous avez une partie des boulangers
pour lesquelles ça n'est pas le cas des
boulangers alors il y a une partie des
boulangers qui sont qu'on appelle j'ai
pas utilisé des mots pénis pour les gens
soient mais les boulangers qui sont
soumis au même règle que les Français
donc ils ont une hausse limité à 15% et
il y en a d'autres qui sont qui devaient
là justement signer leur contrat en fin
d'année 2022 c'est peut-être votre cas
j'ai signé un coup et qui du coup vu un
tarif extrêmement élevé et bien ce qu'on
a décidé avec Bruno Le Maire à la
demande du Président de la République
c'est de dire à ces entreprises toutes
celles qu'on signait un contrat trop
cher en fait vous allez pouvoir
renégocier 100 coûts sans frais votre
contrat pour le plafonner un tarif qui
est d'environ 280 par par mégo par
mégawater ce qui veut dire que on prend
on absorbe une partie du cou et on
demande aux fournisseur d'énergie de
faire un effort pour réduire la facture
justement pour pas que les boulang soit
obligé de mettre la clé sous la porte
pourquoi je vous parle de ça parce qu'il
y a un million de TPE donc un million de
très petites entreprises donc des
boulangers et d'autres débouchés qui
peuvent bénéficier de ce dispositif et à
l'heure à laquelle je vous parle on a
reçu 150 000 demandes alors justement il
faut le faire connaître justement
monsieur Mitz Julien si il y avait eu ça
avant est-ce que vous auriez fermé votre
boulangerie ou est-ce que ça vous auriez
est-ce que ça vous aurez sauvé la
question
que ouais j'aurais pu rester au moins au
moins la fin de l'année l'histoire de
voir ce qui se passait encore un peu de
temps parce que c'est vrai que c'est la
course
dans ma tête je avec la comptable on
cherchait la date butoir à laquelle je
devais fermer pour avoir le moins 2
jours aujourd'hui quand on entend des
beaucoup de boulanger qui nous disent
j'avais de la trésorerie je suis obligé
aujourd'hui de la mettre pour payer
l'électricité on a tous fait ça est-ce
que avec cette mesure là les boulangers
qui sont encore en activité vont pouvoir
garder un petit peu de trésorerie ils
vont pouvoir s'en sortir ou bien c'est
ça
c'est toujours un paquet effet vers
l'avant mais comme dit il faut être plus
réactif et plus engageant qu'est-ce
qu'il faudrait aujourd'hui
pour que voilà redevenir revenir à des
prix corrects toutes les boulangers
puissent perdurer parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que ça ça ferme toutes les
semaines il y a des boulangeries qui
feraient pas un cas isolé c'est
aujourd'hui ça pour vous c'est suffisant
ou pas non qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait je
sais pas je suis pas ministre à l'heure
actuelle mais qu'est-ce qu'il aurait
fallu justement pardon vous pouvez me
parler
de l'énergie déjà en parlant d'énergie
de redevenir un prix correct je veux
dire on a fait x 3 enfin certains ont
fait x 10 x 12 il aurait fallu réagir
plus tôt pour pouvoir anticiper les
choses en fait je pense mieux juste
monsieur monsieur le ministre parce que
je pense que c'est la question qui se
pose tous les Français qui nous
regardent ce soir est-ce que les
fournisseurs d'énergie à l'heure on
parle
font des bénéfices alors ils ont fait
beaucoup de bénéfices oui certains
notamment ont fait beaucoup de bénéfices
et en fait on a récupéré tout ce qui
était du domaine du bénéfice réalisé à
cause du contexte on a récupéré des
milliards d'euros en fait dans le budget
de la France qu'on a voté que le
Parlement a voté il y a pas longtemps on
a récupéré beaucoup beaucoup d'argent
sur les énergéticiens ce qu'on appelle
les super-profils et surprophy liés à la
crise qu'on traverse après faut
comprendre que le prix du l'énergie la
hausse du prix l'énergie elle est très
directement liée au conflit en Ukraine
et donc il y a eu aussi des dérèglements
des prix je rentre pas dans tous les
dans tous les mécanismes mais nous on a
accumulé pas mal de choses des centrales
qui étaient à la règle elles ont repris
leur fonctionnement quasi normal en tout
cas c'est ça va nettement mieux et puis
on établit le prix de l'électricité à
partir du prix du gaz et comme on a fait
un embargo sur le gaz russe ça fait
monter le prix du gaz etc ce qui fait
pas vos affaires j'entends bien c'est
pour expliquer un peu les raisons ils
sont pas des raisons de décisions
politiques locales et plutôt des raisons
qu'on assume en tout cas on assume les
les motifs pour lesquels on a décidé
d'arrêter d'acheter du gaz russe c'est
qu'on veut protéger le la population
ukrainienne et éviter que le conflit ne
s'enlise donc ce qu'on fait au niveau
européen et la France est très active
là-dessus on a obtenu des avancées qui
seront bientôt visibles concrètement
c'est qu'on peut plafonner le prix du
gaz et de l'électricité et qu'on veut
enlever tous les mécanismes qui
provoquent une forme de dérégulation du
rapport entre le gaz et l'électricité là
c'est en cours c'est en cours des
engagement qui ont été pris c'est vrai
qu'il y a une urgence on voit déjà que
le prix de l'électricité cyril a baissé
par rapport à ce qu'il était vous avez
raison de dire qu'il était monté à fois
cette fois dix aujourd'hui on est dans
des horizons qui sont plutôt de l'ordre
de x 3 et on s'attend à ce que ça baisse
de la même manière même si c'est pas
pour les mêmes raisons et pas les mêmes
mécanismes on s'attend à ce que le prix
d'un certain nombre de matières
premières qui s'était envolées je
pensais à lui le beurre etc reviennent
dans des eaux plus normales pourquoi
pourquoi ça reviendrait parce que la
régulation de l'offre et de la demande
d'accord et pas parce que par rapport au
gaz ou à l'énergie la guerre en Ukraine
elle a l'air de elle va durer encore en
impression c'est pas quand ça va ça en
fait
on acquérir les clés on acquiert les
moyens de notre autonomie c'est-à-dire
que d'abord on apporte du gaz qu'on
appelle du gaz non liquéfier qui vient
par bateau on a des centrales de
méthanisation dans différents ports
français qui nous permettent d'acheter
du gaz et de transformer sur notre
territoire ça c'est le la première chose
ensuite on fait des deals des échanges
en européens avec nos voisins allemands
par exemple on va échanger de
l'électricité quand on en a besoin
contre du gaz parce qu'ils en consomme
énormément et de l'autre côté on est
capable d'avoir d'autres échanges avec
d'autres pays européens pour fournir nos
besoins on voit qu'en Espagne au
Portugal ils ont ils ont passé c'est
c'est eux ils sont coupés du circuit
européen c'est ça donc en fait il
devient à personne ce qui veut dire qu'à
la fois si un jour ils en ont besoin ils
ne pourront pas avoir un mécanisme de
solidarité mais là aujourd'hui dans la
situation actuelle ils peuvent dire nous
on établit nos prix laissez nous
tranquille à tous les boulangeries qui
nous regardent ce soir donc là vous
pouvez leur dire
à horizon très proche ça va s'arranger
là donc quoi dans on peut dire quoi dans
un mois dans ce que je dis d'abord au
boulanger et au TPE charcutier au
boucher c'est que pendant la crise covid
on a mis les moyens le fameux quoi qu'il
en coûte pour éviter au commerce de
fermer et quand la crise covid s'est
arrêtée on n'a pas vu les rideaux des
commerçants des artisans se fermer
c'était d'ailleurs pas votre cas ni
votre cas Monsieur Madame parce que vous
avez eu le chômage partiel parce qu'ils
font de soutien de solidarité parce
qu'il y a eu le fameux prêt garanti par
l'État qui a coûté près de 140 millions
d'euros et qu'on assume parce qu'on
s'est dit situation exceptionnelles
mesure exceptionnelles et donc on n'a
pas vocation à laisser nos commerces
mourir au contraire on est plutôt en
train de tout faire pour en réimplanter
pour réanimer les coeurs du village
parce que on s'en est parlé tout à
l'heure c'est là que les gens se
croisent se parlent et je pense que plus
que jamais on a besoin d'endroits on
peut se croiser et se parler sinon on
vit tout seul et quand on vit tout seul
on se finit par se méfier de son voisin
et après on se fait la guerre au lieu de
se faire au lieu de faire la paix
ensemble donc on veut continuer
d'accompagner donc on y met les moyens
ce qu'on dit par contre de manière très
sincère c'est que on ne peut pas l'État
ne peut pas absorber 100% de la hausse
des coûts des matières premières ou de
l'énergie
d'abord parce que ça coûterait très cher
c'est l'impôt des Français et qu'on
finirait par faire banqueroute
collective et on peut pas et ensuite
parce que si c'est l'État qui paye à
chaque fois qu'il y a un prix qui
augmente en fait les prix vont pas
arrêter d'augmenter alors justement la
régulation de l'offre et la demande elle
permet aussi un moment donné de dire à
ceux qui produisent et qui ceux qui
feraient des marges excessives les gars
peut pas continuer parce que là on vend
plus alors aujourd'hui on va de plus en
plus de restaurateurs on va en parler
dans un instant de boulanger de chefs
d'entreprise qui ont pris le PGE sans
parler à l'instant et qui se retrouvent
là avec une hausse toutes les matières
premières une hausse du prix de
l'énergie et en plus le remboursement du
PGE Olivier agrégoire qui était venu
nous voir sur le plateau il y a quelques
semaines nous a dit impossible de dire
pour l'État le PGE terminé on oublie
c'est impossible c'est 140 milliards
d'euros donc 140 milliards d'euros donc
140 milliards d'euros si on le fait on
double on fait plus que doubler les
impôts de tous les Français donc c'est à
dire c'est 4000 euros quasiment par
français de plus d'impôts donc ça on
peut pas le faire par contre ce qui a
été annoncé aussi par Bercy c'est qu'il
y a la création d'un guichet unique
c'est quoi ça veut dire un interlocuteur
dédié au TPE par département en
préfecture vous pouvez le contacter par
mail vous pouvez le contacter par
téléphone vous pouvez aller le voir sur
place qui regarde la situation et qui
vous dit bon ben là si vous passez vous
êtes dans une mauvaise passe mais dans
deux mois vous êtes capable de vous en
sortir on va pas vous laisser couler
pour ça donc on va vous accompagner
d'accord on fait du cas par cas en fait
sur les 140 milliards monsieur Miss on
sait que
si vous allez récupérer quoi 70% des 140
000 vous récupérez jamais les 100%, il y
a plein de gens qui vont fermer boutique
qui rembourseront jamais le PG sauf que
la logique de ce PGE du prêt garantie
par l'État c'est de dire justement on
préfère l'état préfère garantir un prêt
d'accord sans frais pour des entreprises
pour leur éviter de fermer plutôt que
d'aller voir fermer donc ça veut dire
que nous on fait à la base de Paris que
ces entreprises parce qu'on les
accompagne financièrement vont pas faire
mais donc elles pourront rembourser le
prêt derrière et ça a marché pendant la
période covid encore une fois les les là
aujourd'hui c'est je pense enfin je veux
pas parler à votre place mais je pense
que c'est presque plus dur en ce moment
avec le prix des matières premières et
l'énergie que pendant le covid il y
avait des aides mais exceptionnelles
parce qu'on faisait pas face au même
difficulté si vous voulez la difficulté
n'a jamais été aussi importante
qu'aujourd'hui je pense pour tous les
toutes les TPE toutes les on met on met
plus alors pardon je sais qu'on brasse
les milliards et que ça veut pas dire
grand chose parce que on est habitué à
des heures de grandeur mais sachez qu'il
y a quand même 40 plus de 40 milliards
d'euros d'accompagnement face à la
hausse du prix de l'énergie dans notre
pays ce historique en réalité et est-ce
que je vous dis je vous dis plein de
bêtises ce soir peut-être il y a pas de
bêtises pas trop moi
un super impôt pour les plus riches
peut-être pour ces 140 milliards vous
avez dit c'est 4000 € par personne ce
serait 4000 € par citoyens aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il serait peut-être
envisageable de faire un super impôt une
fois je sais pas en 2023 parce qu'on est
dans une situation qui fait qu'on a
connu le la covid là on a une guerre on
a plein de d'artisans qui sont en train
de fermer peut-être pour les plus aisés
vraiment les les plus riches peut-être
faire un super impôt est-ce que c'est
envisageable ou c'est impossible alors
d'abord il faut savoir que quelques
quelques données il y a 10% de la
population donc 10% des plus riches
payent les trois quarts des impôts sur
le revenu donc parce que parfois
j'entends des cours c'est pas votre
discours c'est pas ici mais au Parlement
parfois du côté du peste on explique que
les riches ne payent pas d'impôts après
les trois quarts d'impôt sur l'autre 10%
les trois quarts et c'est normal
deuxième donnée la France avec le
Danemark et le Japon et le pays qui taxe
le plus les fortunes au monde donc la
France n'est pas une oasis ou un havre
d'épanouissement pour les gens pour de
l'argent ils ont des taux d'imposition
qui sont très volontiers supérieurs à
50%. c'est-à-dire qu'à chaque fois
qu'ils gagnent 10 euros on leur en prend
plus de 5 on va pas pleurer ils sont
riches et on l'assume encore une fois
après faut trouver le juste équilibre
Cyril parce que si vous augmentez les
impôts de manière très conséquente même
sur une année pour des gens qui ont
l'argent et qui ont fait le choix de
rester en France et de payer leurs
impôts en France
on peut redécouvrir ce qu'on a ce qu'on
a découvert il y a 15 ans avec le fameux
ras-le-bol fiscal d'en parler la gauche
c'est-à-dire en fait les mecs se barrait
parce qu'ils disaient plutôt que de
payer très cher en france finalement je
vais partir en Belgique ou ailleurs et
ça on a vu ce que ça faisait sur
l'emploi ça faisait ça faisait baisser
l'emploi augmenter le chômage est-ce
qu'on peut pas se dire c'est un impôts
exceptionnel et on régulera l'année
d'après même pour les plus aisés on
frappera peut-être voilà un réajustement
c'est peut-être une limite un prêt que
frais les plus aidés à l'état et que
l'année prochaine tu paierait un petit
peu moins d'impôts est-ce que c'est
envisable c'est impossible d'abord sur
le PGE le prix garanti par l'état de ce
que je sais des données dont je dispose
c'est qu'il est plutôt en train d'être
bien remboursé par d'accord prise parce
que justement elles ont réussi pour sauf
celles qui rencontrent aujourd'hui des
grandes difficultés pour d'autres
raisons mais sinon les entreprises
remboursent leur PGE donc c'est pas le
c'est moins de sujet c'est moi et
ensuite il faut pas confondre parce que
ce qui est pas ce que vous faites mais
j'entendais dans le débat dans le débat
retraite certains élus politiques et
dire vous avez monsieur machin à 100
milliards d'euros il suffit de lui
prendre une taxe sur
en réalité c'est pas 100 millions sur
son compte en banque c'est pas du tout
du tout c'est 100 millions en action
d'entreprise et c'est à dire que c'est
pas quelque chose que vous pouvez taxer
sauf à dire vous faites une spoliation
par l'État d'action d'entreprise qui va
avoir pour effet de faire se casser la
figure d'entreprise qui va avoir pour
effet de créer du chômage avec des
licenciements en masse donc en fait la
solution il faut comprendre que
gouverner ses choisir on fait des choix
et moi je viens de la gauche donc quand
vous me dites accéléré je l'ai fait je
le ferai j'ai pas de j'ai pas de
difficulté conceptuelle avec ça d'accord
vraiment qu'on soit bien d'accord je
défends pas un tel plutôt qu'un tel par
contre il faut toujours trouver le
chemin de crête qui fait que si on va un
peu trop loin les conséquences sont plus
graves que le mal qu'on est capable de
d'apaiser ne serait-ce que
temporairement et ce qu'on voit dans
notre pays et ça c'est factuel c'est que
le chômage il baisse
il baisse même bien même quand
l'activité ralentit le chômage continue
de baisser le chômage des jeunes il a
jamais été aussi battu 15 ans dans notre
pays moi j'ai connu que le chômage de
masse on est à peu près la même
génération bon ben vous depuis que vous
êtes à l'école vous savez que le chômage
c'est le chômage de masse et quand on
sort de l'école on sait pas si on
trouvera du boulot aujourd'hui c'est
beaucoup moins le cas et on parle même
du plein emploi dans ma circonscription
en Isère on est au pleine emploi c'est à
dire que on rame plutôt pour trouver des
salariés que pour trouver du boulot bon
et on veut continuer ça parce que c'est
de la dépense publique en moins parce
que c'est des gens qui sont pas dans la
misère et parce que ce sont des Français
des classes moyennes qui vivent de leur
travail et n'ont pas de l'Assistance
publique donc on veut pas casser cette
dynamique là or on constate
qu'aujourd'hui la France est redevenue
le pays le plus attractif d'Europe c'est
là où les les entreprises s'implantes
ont créé davantage d'emploi on
réimplante des usines on sera capable de
fabriquer nous-mêmes des matières
premières demain ce qui nous évitera de
dépendre de payer étrangers avec tout ce
qu'on voit que comme séquence quand ça
devient instable sur le plan politique
etc donc c'est ce qu'on appelle la
souveraineté en fait de notre pays et
elle repose sur un équilibre et encore
une fois cet équilibre aujourd'hui les
chiffres nous montrent qu'on a plutôt
trouvé parce que les impôts baisse
s'effectuelle c'est factuel le chômage
baisse et on recrée de la richesse et de
l'emploi dans notre pays alors donc pour
malheureusement pour pour vous et c'est
vrai que ça ça nous font le cœur voilà
vous avez dû fermer
vos trois votre boulangerie aujourd'hui
pour tous ceux qui nous regardent on
peut les rassurer
un peu je peux dire vraiment que et
alors j'en ai parlé avec mes collègues
à Bercy le président parle régulièrement
la première ministre aussi enfin on veut
continuer de faire ce qu'on a fait
pendant la crise covid c'est-à-dire
permettre aux petits commerces de rester
debout et même de rouvrir donc moi j'ai
j'ai compris que vous avez de
l'expérience c'était physique vous
voulez faire autre chose donc si vous
voulez on pourra discuter mais peut-être
en dehors de l'émission de ce qui vous
intéresse et si je peux vous aider pour
vous donner quelques relais je le ferai
vraiment avec avec plaisir et sans sans
aucune contrepartie j'ai rien à vendre
néanmoins on a besoin d'avoir des
artisans on a besoin d'avoir des gens
qui ont du savoir-faire
qui ont été formés pour faire ça on en a
besoin donc si vraiment vous me dites
que c'est derrière vous que c'est vous
allez faire autre chose et ben écoutez
je vous souhaite d'être heureux dans ce
que vous allez
engager comme comme carrière comme
métier demain si vous dites
le plus dur est derrière nous peut-être
qu'on peut se relancer vous trouverez
une porte ouverte mais psychologiquement
comment vous voulez qu'on se remette de
ça en fait
je sais pas j'ai pas la réponse à votre
question j'ai pas traversé ça c'est pas
possible moi je vous le dis c'est
Stéphane vous m'avez dit que c'était
votre premier c'était votre premier
commerce
c'est moi on parlait du covid moi par
exemple pour mon cas de figure pour le
covid j'ai le droit à 0 aide après comme
on disait les boulangers étaient mais
vous avez vous êtes resté ouvert vous
moi je suis resté oui bon c'est
essentiel mais c'était très compliqué
parce qu'on n'avait pas de clients parce
qu'ils avaient pas le droit de sortir ou
il savait pas ce qu'il a le droit de
faire enfin bref c'était un peu le
bordel mais on a réussi à tenir le coup
et comme vous disiez effectivement c'est
relevé de ça et on était très fiers on
s'est dit on a vu le pire
professionnel moi de 17 ans de métier et
au final là on voit l'inflation c'est
c'est pire que tout en fait
et moi j'ai pas j'attends du
gouvernement en fait qui se battent pour
nous comme on dit on est le plus
commerce préféré des Français on a quand
même brandi la baguette au patrimoine et
matrule l'UNESCO c'est vrai on est fier
de l'avoir en France il y a pas de souci
mais nous on attend que l'État peut-être
se battent pour nous différemment
peut-être je sais pas je suis pas
politicien je serai pas vous dire
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire qu'est-ce
qu'il faut pas faire mais voilà nous on
demande juste à faire notre boulot comme
vous dites notre savoir-faire c'est tout
ce qu'on demandait nous en fait c'est
pas notre job d'aller sur la télé ou de
sortir comme ça nous c'est c'est
vraiment notre boulot nos labos c'est
notre vie c'est vous parlerez avec des
passionnés vous diront la même chose les
collègues c'est tous pareils donc voilà
peut-être que le gouvernement devrait
peut-être je sais pas changer la
dynamique ou regarder d'un autre angle
peut-être je sais pas est-ce que vous
alors il y a des choses mais je vais pas
vous faire tout la panache de tout ce
qu'on fait mais il y a un truc que
j'aime beaucoup moins c'est ce qu'on
appelle action cœur de ville ça vous
parle pas absolument pas non bon action
cœur de ville on le fait dans un peu
plus de 200 villes de taille moyenne
pour le coup c'est moins des villages
mais c'est un peu dans l'esprit de ce
que je disais tout à l'heure recréer des
zones de rencontres où les gens c'est à
dire qu'on essaye de lutter contre
l'implantation excessive de super centre
commerciaux à l'extérieur des villes
parce que vous prenez votre bagnole vous
garez sur un parking vous croisez
personne faites vos courses vous rentrez
chez vous et vous restez seul et on se
dit qu'en fait pour créer une dynamique
collective et des mécanismes de
solidarité que les gens se rencontrent
il faut qu'on anime les coeurs de ville
et donc l'État finance les collectivités
qui participent à ça pour renforcer
moderniser le cœur des centres villes de
ces villes de taille moyenne et
réimplanter des commerces moi je vous
dis une chose il y a pas de
fonctionnaire boulanger sauf dans les
administrations publiques donc vous êtes
un libéral un commerçant vous avez
ouvert votre votre commerce etc
moi je suis à peu près certain en tout
cas j'espère qu'il y a des élus locaux
qui nous écoutent ce soir il y en a
peut-être un certain nombre d'entre eux
qui se disent moi Julien il a l'air
motivé il est jeune il a dû savoir faire
j'ai plus de boulangerie chez moi depuis
quelques années ça m'intéresse en
réimplanter un peut-être qu'on vous
appellera qu'on vous proposera des aides
aussi localement parce que les
collectivités peuvent vous apporter des
aides quand elles ont besoin de faire
venir des commerces et que là peut-être
que vous retrouverez le goût de de cette
prise de risque mais sinon je vous
souhaite de toute façon d'être heureux
dans votre dans votre vie
professionnelle mais comme Monsieur misk
disait un truc qui est un instant je
vous sens quand même passionné Julien et
vraiment on le sent vraiment vous êtes
passionné vous avez dit le labo c'est ma
passion
c'est la passion du métier vous allez
reprendre la boulangerie et j'espère
voilà il y en a qui me le disent aussi
plus tard mais là dans l'immédiat non
merci à vous de m'avoir invité merci
Monsieur on va essayer de trouver des
solutions pour vous merci merci beaucoup
merci Raphaël merci